New Jersey has a severe pension crisis.
The unfunded liabilities for pensions is
95 billion dollars. The entire New Jersey
state budget is 35 billion dollars. New
Jersey does not have the money to pay
for these pensions. How did New Jersey get
into this situation?
The simple answer is that it is a direct
result of the enormous political power
of the New Jersey Education Association,
the state's largest teachers union. Over
the course of the last 20 years,
NJEA has spent over 800 million dollars
on its various political tools. With that
kind of money,
NJEA got what it wanted on pensions.
Recently NJEA sought to enshrine this
bankrupt system in the state
constitution. Senate President Steve
Sweeney stood up to NJEA. NJEA then
exacted revenge by vowing to support
senator Sweeney's opponent in the
Democratic gubernatorial primary and
forcing Sweeney to withdraw from the
race. Now NJEA has a politician who will
do its bidding,
thus encapsulating the New Jersey pension crisis.
I'd like to know what you think about
New Jersey's pension crisis.
Let us know in the comments section, and
also let us know what other topics you
want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.